now how else would you prove this uh one
of the tricky things about a proof like
this is it relies on your knowledge of
playing geometry is there another way to
do it well there is I'm going to show
you a second proof it's considerably
longer and I wouldn't recommend it as
like I showed you this proof here
because I think it's preferable and it's
a lot more elegant but what's great
about the proof that I'm about to show
you is it doesn't rely on as much
knowledge of properties and it does end
up being a bit of algebraic soup but a
kind of the power of algebra and this
was um Renee descar's key Insight when
he uh sort of devised the Cartesian
plane that's why we named it after him
is that you can State all of the
geometric relationships that you can see
here in terms of coordinates that you
can then manipulate algebraically so he
kind of created this bridge from algebra
which seemed to just be about you know
interacting numbers and geometry and
shapes which seem to be a lot more free
form right so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to call this proof2
coordinate geometry
now one of the other attractive things
about this uh
method despite the fact that it will be
longer and I think harder is that you
don't even need to start with a circle
right all you need to know is there is
some right angle here oh I didn't mean
to highlight that there's some right
angle here and what that will create is
um a a diameter that P sort of can move
around that the circle of that diameter
on a Locus or Locus depending on how you
like to pronounce it so what I'm going
to do is create that construction right
all I know is there's some right angle
APB and I want to prove that a b is the
diameter right so let's create this to
start with so if I have a triangle
let's do something like this
let's make it a little more right angled
looking
like I can do better than that there you
go
all right let's shift this over so I've
got a little more space that'll do all
right so um if I again have some point p
and it can move about but what I know
about it is that there's a right angle
there okay and then I've got some
arbitrary a and some arbitrary B so they
are locked in some constant position so
they do actually have coordinates but I
don't know what they are so I'm just
going to call them X1 y1 and X2 Y2 and
the fact that I don't know where they
are is another way of saying that this
is generally true they can be anywhere
so I know it's a bit funny because it's
all pro numerals but I want you to think
about X1 and y1 as constants X2 and Y2
as constants but X Y can change remember
when I first did this
Andrew I drew this and I said hey look
you can actually move uh
uh let's do it this way you can actually
move P to some other position so long as
you fix a and b in place P can be
anywhere and it will still be 90 degrees
so that's why I have described X comma y
this point over here those are actual
variables okay so these are generalized
positions somewhere and these things uh
they can actually change throughout this
situation
so what am I looking for here well I'm
suggesting a b is a diameter so
somewhere on this diameter there is the
center of the circle and the center of
the the circle will be the the midpoint
of the diameter right so if I call that
M the reason why this is helpful is I
know where that that midpoint is going
to be I can calculate it using just a
fairly standard Corner geometry formula
right this is going to be I'll take the
average of the x coordinates so that's
X1 plus X2 divided by two and then I'll
take the average of the Y coordinates y1
plus Y2 on 2. there you go
now the reason why this is helpful is I
can then say hey if there's some you
know mystical Circle right something uh
like this wow that's horrendously drawn
but you get the idea okay if I've got
some circle like so no it's not bad
actually
um it's an imaginary Circle I don't know
where it actually is right but I can say
there should be an equation that governs
X Y that makes it move along this circle
right I know what the center of the
circle is here are its coordinates and I
also know the radius of the circle or I
can calculate it it's going to be this
length here this is the radius here from
the midpoint to either A or B then that
radius I'll just get rid of this circle
here now because it's just imaginary at
the moment this radius here is just
going to be half that length a b and I
can just use the distance formula for
that right so I can State all of that in
a required to prove you know summary
right I can say what I'm required to
prove is that X and Y and by the way I'm
saying this X and this y over here they
move along through coordinate space such
that they're on the send they're on the
circumference of this circle right now I
just I've got the center I've got the
radius what's the equation of that
Circle and the answer is it's going to
be
X take away uh that the the x
coordinates of the center which I've
just sort of stated right here so that's
going to be X1 plus X2 onto all squared
I repeat the same thing for y so it's y
take away the y coordinate of the center
y1 plus Y2
onto all squared and what that's equal
to is the radius squared so I said that
the radius would be half of a b all
squared this is my destination now just
before we go any further and start to
set about proving this right what I love
about just making this statement right
here
is at least personally this kind of
solves that was a bad rectangle I guess
let's just make a small one there we go
it kind of solves a mystery that I had
all the way through going through school
and being asked to prove stuff in maths
class right you know you'd get an exam
question it would say prove this and
then it would assign three marks to it
right and I always thought to myself why
am I jumping through these soups to
prove a thing that like you wouldn't ask
me to prove it unless you already knew
that it was true right like wouldn't it
be I mean but I I really hope um that
thing that's never happened to you it's
happened to people
um throughout throughout the world where
you get asked to prove something that's
false and you put all these work and
time in and you're like what do you mean
I couldn't prove this it's it's not true
right
um of course if they set this exercise
or this question or this exam task for
you they know that it's true already so
why are they putting you through the
motions to prove that it's true if they
already know and I think at least part
of the answer
part of the answer is that actually this
is the way that mathematics is created
we have a bunch of things that we don't
really know to be true can you imagine
if we we Round the Clock I went back in
time and we knew you know we'd proved
okay yeah that um the uh if you've got
the diameter you know that that try that
angle in the semicircle on the
circumference has to be 90 degrees but
how do we prove that you know doing it
in reverse and if we proved it this way
you know someone to double check this is
the way we know how answers are true you
can arrive at them from multiple
different perspectives
how would we actually prove that this
hunch that we've got actually is valid
well you would say I think that this is
the case I think that there should be a
circle with this particular Center and
this particular radius along which X
comma y can move but I don't actually
know and so this is just a hunch and I'm
going to try and use deductive logic
from what I know and and sort of reason
reason to hopefully arrive at this point
at the end
all right so that's enough Preamble
let's get to the proof what do I
actually know here precious little I
just know about this right angle okay
now the right angle in Quantum geometry
terms means that if you have a look at
this interval here or the line that goes
through it and if you compare it to this
interval over here what you know is that
these two lines are perpendicular which
has produces a relationship between
their gradients namely that they are
negative reciprocals of each other or
that if you multiply them together you
get negative one so let me just sort of
write out some of that logic right I can
say
um since
AP is perpendicular to BP what I can say
is the gradient of AP times the gradient
of BP is equal to negative one well what
are the gradient of AP and BP I just
have to use the gradient formula from
this point to a and then from this point
to B so hopefully if you remember your
gradient formula you can say that you've
got uh rise over run so it should be
y minus y1 over x minus X1
multiplied by y minus Y2 on x minus X2
that's all equal to negative 1. so you
can see here is the rise over run for AP
here's the rise over run for BP
okay now uh have a think right where I'm
headed towards is going to be this thing
here which is kind of this quadratic in
X and it's quadratic and Y when you have
a look at this at least you know
um from the statement I'm heading in the
right direction not only did I start
from something I know to be true but
just have a look you can see there's
wise there and then there's X's here
um so I've got the the Y squared and I'm
going to have the x squared if I can
actually Wade through all of this
algebra right so let's have a go at
train to begin that process you can see
here I've got
y minus y1 and Y minus y 2 up on the
numerator and I can make this a bit
easier for me to deal with if I take
this x minus X1 and the x minus X2
multiply it across the other side so I
don't have as many fractions I mean
we're not going to escape the fractions
but these fractions at least are
constant whereas these fractions here
I've got you know
um actual variables flying around there
so I've got a minus sign here and then
I've got the x minus X1
x minus X 2. so again just to make
things a bit easier for me to deal with
I'm going to add that term you see on
the right hand side to both sides so
that I've got zero on the on the right
so I've got x minus X1
uh x minus X 2. I've just added that to
both sides that's why it's positive now
plus everything that was there before
which is this
and this is equal to zero